this is the hotel that Elvis built today
it's Westgate Las Vegas before that it
was the Las Vegas Hilton but it opened
in 1969 as the international and the
headliner was Elvis Presley in fact he
lived here two months out of the year on
the top floor and there are stories now
of people seeing his Spirit or hearing
him or feeling his presence
I was invited to stay in the Elvis suite
for a night to see if Elvis ever really
left the building Elvis once lived here
and many say he's still a resident at
Westgate you'll have people that that
swore on some of the higher floors that
they could swear they saw Elvis down the
hall here in this Suite people have said
they've heard Elvis music but there's no
radio or stereo on anywhere they'll talk
about feeling his presence Gordon Prouty
says he's heard plenty of stories since
coming on board at the hotel and says
one time he wondered if the king of rock
and roll was playing a prank on him and
then I swear when we came in we heard
laughing it's never anything that that's
threatening it's always entertaining
down in the theater we've had a number
of entertainers who have been in the
dressing room and just said for whatever
reason they just felt like somebody was
there and they just got the feeling that
that it was you know spirit that had
been there before and they kept thinking
I know it's Elvis I know it's Elvis but
when I experienced something similar
during my stay in the Elvis Suite all I
could do was wait
and wait
maybe it wouldn't happen until after
dark so I decided to learn more about
Elvis encounters from Presley's
stepbrother David Stanley so I grew up
here and this was where his bedroom was
I can remember him sitting on his bed
and he said many hours talking to Elvis
about Vegas and life and what we're
doing and what he's doing
just brings back a lot of memories
Stanley met Elvis when he was four years
old when his mom married Elvis's dad the
person that were grateful he put us to
bed I would never forget he prayed with
us and put us to bed and thank God for
it all this was new to me
and uh somebody said that's Elvis
Presley to me it was just some guy being
nice to me Stanley says he and Presley
remained close until his death in 1977.
he shares many of his memories in his
book my brother Elvis which includes
times where Stanley says he too has felt
his presence in the hotel I'm in my
sweet
there's a light over against the wall
there's no way to come on unless you get
up out of the bed walk over and turn it
on
so I'm laying in bed one night and I
feel this feeling I feel this presence
of Elvis and I just said Elvis that's
you
like turns on no way the light can come
on
no no thing on the wall you have to get
out of bed and go do it okay okay okay
okay okay
so I get up turn off the light and I go
to the bathroom and I'm sitting right
that lights on when I come out of this
bathroom I was what are you doing and
what do you want sure enough I walk out
with lights on I sit down in the chair
there's an empty chair okay boss what's
up with those stories in mind I went
back to waiting for Elvis
and waiting and wondering if I too would
feel his presence later that night I
walked the darkened hallways in search
of my own Elvis story it is kind of a
little spooky
middle of the night all the lights off
14 000 square feet
but I haven't seen Elvis
yet
while I didn't get my own personal Elvis
encounter I did leave with some sort of
new connection and better understanding
of the legend of the king of rock and
roll
[Music]
everybody knows
[Music]